sehr geehrte frau professor vielen dank
für die netten worte liebe freunde allen
voran lieber horst seehofer vielen
vielen dank für die einladung ist eine
große freude und ehre für mich heute bei
eurem parteitag dabei sein zu dürfen
vielen vielen dank für die einladungen
für die möglichkeit kommen zu dürfen
lieber andreas scheuer vielen dank für
die möglichkeit einmal solch einen
parteitag erleben zu dürfen weil man so
wie ich mit 16 beginnt sich politisch zu
engagieren dann ist man mit 30 zwar noch
nicht alt aber man hat schon den einen
oder anderen partei tag gesehen so einen
parteitag durfte ich noch nicht sehen
lieber andreas vielen dank für die
möglichkeit einmal bei einem wirklich
beeindruckenden parteitag auch dabei
sein zu dürfen
liebe freunde wenn man bayern und
österreich
googelt dann vervollständigt google mit
den worten bayern und österreich gehören
zusammen
jetzt hat google nicht immer recht und
als außenminister
kenne ich unsere staatsgrenze in der tat
aber in diesem fall trifft es doch ein
stück weit zu und ein österreichischer
bundeskanzler hat einmal sogar so weit
getrieben dass er gesagt hat wenn der
österreicher ins ausland fährt dann
fährt am liebsten nach bayern weil da
ist er nicht mehr ganz in österreich und
noch nicht so richtig in deutschland ich
weiß nicht ob man das in bayern auch so
teilen würde diese einschätzung in
österreich war das ein
sozialdemokratischer bundeskanzler der
das gesagt hat aber ich glaube in diesem
fall hat er fast recht und wenn ich mir
die tourismuszahlen so ansehe dann kann
ich nur sagen ich habe das gefühl die
bayern kommen auch relativ gern nach
bereich und das ist gut so wir haben
eine sehr starke verbundenheit zwischen
österreich und bayern das zeigen nicht
nur die tourismuszahlen sondern auch
unsere wirtschaftsdaten aus unserer
perspektive ist bayern mit abstand unser
wichtigster wirtschaftspartner und es
gibt kein anderes land in dem so viele
auslandsösterreicher leben wie in bayern
immerhin fast 100000 an der zahl
aber die wahre verbundenheit die lässt
sich ja bekanntlich nicht mit zahlen
messen sondern die muss man erleben und
ich ganz persönlich dürfte diese
verbundenheit zwischen bayern und
österreich vor allem im letzten jahr in
den letzten 18 monaten der
flüchtlingsfrage erleben
es gab andere die in der vergangenheit
stark dafür eingetreten sind dass es
eine unbeschränkte aufnahme in
mitteleuropa geben soll auch in
österreich war das zu beginn die
mehrheitsmeinung und es waren wir die
bayern und einzelne österreicher die von
anfang an hier eine andere position
verfolgt haben wir waren von anfang an
der meinung dass das weiter winken von
flüchtlingen der falsche weg ist und das
ist dazu führt dass in griechenland
menschen demonstrieren dass sie vom eu
land griechenland ins nicht-eu-land
mazedonien weiter fliegen dürfen
und das hat dazu geführt dass in
österreich 90.000 menschen einen
asylantrag gestellt haben während in
unserem nachbarland slowenien wo die
menschen auch schon sicher waren und
fast alle durchgezogen sind nicht einmal
tausend menschen einen asylantrag
gestellt haben
die grenzen zwischen der suche nach
schutz und der suche nach einem besseren
leben die sind in der tat sehr stark
verschwommen und auch wenn das
menschlich zu 100% nachvollziehbar ist
so ist es trotzdem
eine politik die nicht wirklich zu einem
positiven ergebnis führt denn je mehr
menschen sich auf den weg machen desto
mehr verdienen die schlepper und desto
mehr menschen verlieren auch ihr leben
bei der gefährlichen überfahrt übers
mittelmeer
ich bin daher froh dass es uns anfang
des jahres gelungen ist mit den
westbalkan staaten gemeinsam in wien die
schließung der west balkan route zu
vereinbaren
das hat den zustrom nicht gänzlich
beendet
aber es ist uns gelungen von 15.000
menschen an spitzentagen auf weniger auf
als 1000 menschen zu kommen und es hat
dazu geführt dass der zustrom deutlich
geringer worden ist
ich möchte nur gleichzeitig davor warnen
dass wir glauben die situation sei jetzt
gelöst denn es ist nach wie vor so dass
jemand der in italien an kommt von der
insel aufs festland gebracht wird und
sich vom festland in absehbarer zeit in
richtung norden auf den weg macht wir
müssen endlich mehr hilfe vor ort
einführen
wir müssen gleichzeitig unsere
außengrenzen besser schützen und wir
brauchen endlich die politik die klar
sagt wer sich illegal auf den weg nach
europa macht der wird nicht nach
mitteleuropa durchkommen
solange liebe freunde die rettung im
mittelmeer mit dem ticket nach
mitteleuropa verbunden ist werden sich
mehr und mehr menschen auf den weg
machen die schlepper werden mit diesem
furchtbaren geschäft viel geld verdienen
und die zahl der toten wird nicht
weniger werden
wir müssen als europa entscheiden wer zu
uns durch kommt und nicht die schlepper
mittlerweile sind wir in einer phase
angelangt wo die herausforderung nicht
nur heißt den zustrom zu reduzieren
sondern vor allem auch die menschen die
zu uns gekommen sind und bei uns bleiben
dürfen auch bestmöglich zu integrieren
und ich kann mich noch ganz gut erinnern
als ich begonnen hat mich politisch zu
engagieren bei einem der ersten
wahlkämpfe wo ich als wahlhelfer aktiv
war gab es damals ein seminar für neue
wahlkämpfer unter trainer dort hat uns
gesagt beim integrationsthema das sei
ein passiv thema und ich habe mir damals
die frage gestellt was ist ein passiv
thema und er hat gemeint das ist ganz
leicht
es gibt aktiv themen die kommunizieren
wir und es gibt passiv themen zu denen
kommunizieren wir nicht und wenn uns
jemand darauf anspricht dann wechseln
wir möglichst schnell auf ein aktiv
thema ich habe mich dann zu wort
gemeldet und hat gemeint als jemand der
seinen bezirk kommt wo 50 prozent der
menschen in meiner schulklasse
migrationshintergrund haben ist es im
wahlkampf schwierig bei der migration
und integrationsfrage zu sagen das sei
ein passiv thema der trainer hat genickt
und dann gemeint er schlägt vor es
trotzdem so zu machen
wir haben es versucht es hat nicht
sonderlich gut funktioniert das thema
war damals schon im wahlkampf ein aktiv
thema für die bevölkerung und die
bevölkerung hat sich zu recht erwartet
dass auch eine bürgerliche partei sich
damit auseinandersetzt dass wir dieses
thema nicht den linken und den rechten
überlassen
und ich sage mittlerweile aus voller
überzeugung wir dürfen dieses thema
weder links noch rechts überlassen denn
die rechten freuen sich dass es probleme
gibt um sie zu plakatieren sie noch
größer zu machen und damit wählerstimmen
zu gewinnen und die linken glauben dass
das totschweigen von problemen diese
alleine lösen wird es braucht liebe
freunde gerade in der herausforderung
der integration eine ordentliche
christlich-soziale eine ordentliche
bürgerliche politik es muss für uns klar
sein dass jeder der in unserem land lebt
nicht danach beurteilt wird welche
hautfarbe religion oder herkunft er hat
sondern dass er danach beurteilt wird
wasser in unserem land weiterbringen
möchte und wenn das zusammenleben
funktionieren soll dann braucht ein
klares jahr zum vermitteln der deutschen
sprache es braucht ein klares ja zur
teilhabe in arbeitsmarkt und ehrenamt
und vor allem wenn viele menschen aus
anderen kulturkreisen zu uns kommen wie
bei der flüchtlingsbewegung des letzten
und dieses jahres dann braucht auch ein
klares jahr dazu dass wir unsere
grundwerte die uns in europa verbinden
auch vermitteln wollen
und ich bin froh dass die csu sich mit
dem thema der integration
auseinandersetzt
dass ihr aber auch auf dem schwierigen
thema des zusammenlebens mit dem islam
stellt denn viele sagen heute zwei jahre
zur wertevermittlung aber wollen sich
nicht mit der frage des islam
auseinandersetzen zu überlassen die
auseinandersetzung mit dem thema das ist
und dann all jenen die sagen der islam
hat mit all den problemen die wir haben
bis hin zum terrorismus nichts zu tun
oder mit all jenen die auf der anderen
seite sagen der islam ist schuld an ein
problemen der integration bis hin zum
terrorismus
ich halte beide thesen für falsch was
wir brauchen ist eine differenzierte
aber klare auseinandersetzung auch mit
der frage des islams und da muss uns
klar sein wer sich zur religionsfreiheit
bekennt der muss auch jedem zugestehen
seine religion auszuleben
aber der politische islamismus der hat
mit religionsfreiheit nichts zu tun
er ist die basis für radikalisierung und
terror
und er hat in unserer gesellschaft
definitiv keinen platz
wir haben daher in österreich schon
verlangen einem islam gesetz eingeführt
das einerseits muslimen rechte gibt die
ihnen zustehen wie das recht auf
seelsorge in spitälern oder das recht
einen friedhof zu errichten
aber wir haben gleichzeitig die
finanzierung aus dem ausland untersagt
weil es unserer meinung nach eben nicht
sein kann dass direkt aus saudi arabien
oder anderen islamischen ländern
moscheen mitten in wien finanziert
werden
aber nicht nur aus einer großzügigkeit
heraus sondern mit dem klaren ziel dort
einfluss zu nehmen und es kann aus
unserer sicht auch nicht sein dass zum
beispiel in sarajevo mitten in bosnien
herzegowina frauen aus islamischen
staaten dafür bezahlt werden durch die
straßen in bosnien vollverschleiert zu
gehen um das stadtbild zu verändern und
somit einfluss auf die gesellschaft zu
nehmen wenn wir in österreich und in
deutschland gemeinsam über 1000 foren
weiter haben sie sich entschieden haben
in syrien und im irak zu vergewaltigen
zu morden und religiöse minderheiten aus
zu löschen
dann ist es unsere pflicht gegen diese
terroristen nicht nur vor ort
militärisch anzukämpfen
sondern es ist meiner meinung nach
unsere pflicht auch gegen die basis
dahinter gegen den politischen
islamismus in unserem land in unseren
gesellschaften polizeilich und
ideologisch vorzugehen
wenn wir das nicht tun dann wird sich
unsere gesellschaft in eine richtung
verändern die wir definitiv nicht wollen
können und ich freue mich dass ihr euch
in eurem leitantrag so intensiv mit
diesem thema beschäftigt weil ich
oftmals auf europäischer ebene erlebe
dass man sich zwar sorgen darüber macht
wie die entwicklung in der türkei in
saudi arabien oder anderswo ist aber
viel zu oft darauf vergisst welche
entwicklungen es mittlerweile mitten in
unseren eigenen gesellschaften gibt und
wenn ich beim thema europa angelangt bin
und den manfred weber hier in der ersten
reihe sitzen sie er dann erlaubt mir
noch ein paar abschließende gedanken zu
unserer europäischen union
ich möchte zunächst einmal dir lieber
manfred danken für die art und weise wie
du dort für die europäische volkspartei
tätig bist nämlich in einem ausmaß dass
viele österreicher schon der meinung
sind du bist ein österreicher weil du
uns so gut vertritt
wir sind sehr dankbar dass du in vielen
fragen linie halston aus unserer sicht
ist es gerade in einer zeit der krisen
der ukraine konflikt im osten
der putschversuch und die
säuberungswelle in der türkei und syrien
konflikt im süden aber auch der krisen
innerhalb der europäischen union
das flexi quoten oder die
flüchtlingskrise ist es notwendig eine
ganz klare position zu vertreten ich
glaube dass es zum ersten wichtig ist
alles zu tun und diese aktuellen krisen
innerhalb der europäischen union des brh
exit das praxisforum und die damit
verbundene notwendigkeit des austritts
aber auch die flüchtlingsfrage unter
kontrolle zu bringen
es ist zum zweiten aus meiner sicht
notwendig dass wir das ziel einer
subsidiären europäischen union wieder
stärker verfolgen die stark in den
großen fragen ist aber die in den
kleinen themen auch die
entscheidungskompetenz bei den
nationalstaaten und regionen belässt und
ich glaube wir brauchen eine europäische
union die auch den mut hat
außenpolitisch klar aufzutreten türkei
deal hin oder her
bei den verhaftungswellen in der türkei
dürfen wir nicht wegsehen wenn die
opposition mundtot gemacht werden soll
journalisten eingespart werden oder die
todesstrafe eingeführt werden soll
dann hat diese türkei definitiv keinen
platz in unserer europäischen union
liebe freunde ich habe bei der herfahrt
euren leitantrag sehr genau angeschaut
zu dem ich nur gratulieren kann und
merke dass wir in vielen punkten
übereinstimmen politisch wirtschaftlich
auch im sport der mit alaba der beste
österreichische fußball spieler zeigt
dass das zusammenspiel mit bayern
münchen ganz gut funktioniert und auch
hier die österreichische bayerische
freundschaft gelebt wird aber ich möchte
darüber hinaus hat die möglichkeit
nutzen um auch ganz persönlich danke zu
sagen
wir haben im letzten jahr in der
flüchtlingspolitik in der
migrationspolitik viele entscheidungen
getroffen die heute zustimmung ernten
aber als wir sie getroffen haben gab es
nur kritik als wird die west balkan
route in wien geschlossen haben
gemeinsam mit den staaten des
westbalkans sind wir von fast allen
seiten kritisiert worden
und es war für mich auch persönlich
nicht einfach mit dem gefühl schlafen zu
gehen jeden tag nicht zu wissen ob die
mazedonische polizei dem druck von die
domäne standhält und die grenze am
nächsten tag in der früh auch wirklich
noch geschlossen ist und ich möchte er
in diesem zusammenhang die möglichkeit
nutzen um euch danke zu sagen denn die
unterstützung aus bayern die war in
diesen schwierigen tagen stets da und
die unterstützung von einem mann
die war ohnehin eine ständige und
lautstärke vielen dank
eure ministerpräsidenten vielen dank dir
lieber horst seehofer für all die
unterstützung in dieser für mich
teilweise auch persönlich sehr
schwierigen phase und euch vielen dank
für die einladung schön dabei sein zu
dürfen
liebe freunde
doch
vielen dank
ja lieber sebastian kurz ich hab dir
nicht zu viel versprochen die bayern
stehen zu ihrem wort dass du einen
parteitag erlebt der sich freut auf
deinem besuch weil du auch klare worte
findet nicht nur zu unserer
nachbarschaftlichen freundschaft sondern
auch zu vielen politischen inhalten wir
müssen in europa gut zusammenhalten
deswegen möchten wir die kraft spenden
mit einem bayerischen löwen dieser
bayerische löwe soll ich am parteitag
erinnern soll auf seinem schreibtisch
stehen
und wenn du hilfe brauchst dass bayern
dann erinnerst du dich an den
bayerischen löwen und ruft uns einfach
an wir helfen
danke dass du bist vielen vielen dank
für die einladung